MALE SPEAKER 1: Hi, guys.
Welcome to our second
day here at I/O.
We're so excited to
have you guys here.
Have a packed house up for
the YouTube distribute talks.
And basically what we
want to get at here
is there's the design
and development
part of the process.
But once you've built
a great product,
how do you get it out there.
And I can't think of a
better example than Secret
and all the amazing
work, David, you've
done to get your
product out there.
So thank you so
much for joining us.
DAVID: Of course.
No worries.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
So why don't you
let us-- I know I've
been using the app obsessively.
So take myself out of
the picture, can tell us
for people who haven't used
Secret, what exactly it is.
How do you interact with it?
DAVID: Sure.
So Secret is, I
would say, probably
the first anonymous
social application.
Which might seem at
odds with each other.
But what we do is we connect
people with their friends,
but anonymously.
So when you come on
and post, the postings
that you think and feel, and
your friends know it's you,
but they don't know-- well, they
know it's one of their friends.
But they don't know
who it is exactly.
And this has created a really,
really interesting network
of content.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Aweome.
And take us back to
through the days.
When did you guys launch?
DAVID: Yeah, so we launched
January 30 of this year.
So it was about five months,
something like that. ago.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So let's
rewind back those five months.
What was day one like,
when you put it out there.
Tell me about your first users.
DAVID: So I remember--
well, we started
building it in mid November.
So in mid November, we had
an app before that also
called Secret, but it was
more about anonymous one
to one messaging.
But we wanted
something that people
would come back every day.
So you're like well, you know,
what if we built something
where you just broadcast
out to your friends.
And so it's something that
they can see and come back
to every day as stream of stuff.
So we tested it out with
about 200 of our friends
over a period of about
2 and 1/2 months.
And you know, January
30 we're like,
well it's good enough to launch.
We think design is OK.
Like, we'll just put it
out there and kind of
slip it out there quietly.
And so I remember
I was introduced
to Mike Isaac, who was
formally at Re/code.
And I'm like, hey.
We met over beers.
I'm like hey dude,
like we have this app.
Like maybe you want
to write about it.
I don't know.
So I wanted to just kind
of get it out there.
And so he did that.
He wrote one article.
And then there was a bunch
of people joined here
in Silicon Valley.
And because the way
the product works
where it connects
your social graph,
it was immediate that
such a dense network
here that people were
just instantly connected.
And they're connected
to stuff that
meant-- it was
interesting to them.
It was like tech
stuff and things
that, rumors and all that.
So it just like kind of blew
up and took off from there.
And a bunch of people
started writing about it.
And we just started hanging on.
MALE SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
Yeah, it seems that you guys
did a terrific job of overcoming
the networking effect that a
social network like yourself
needs.
DAVID: Yeah, I mean, especially
in a dense network like this.
But then after that, like
how do you break out of that?
How do you get into
other areas, right.
We saw a lot in the
beginning in California,
mostly Silicon Valley,
and then LA and New York.
These are kind of
our dense networks.
And people were like
well, all the secrets
are just about tech.
They're just about whatever.
But over time, it's become
much more mainstream.
And now even other
countries-- Russia
caught on very, very big.
Honestly, I can't give you
the formula for how it works.
MALE SPEAKER 1: There's a
lot of secrets in Russia.
DAVID: There's a lot of secrets.
MALE SPEAKER 1: On and off
your platforms, though.
DAVID: Yeah.
Yes.
It was perfect.
But as far as
distribution goes, I
think it's just about
making a product that people
want to use.
And when you have a
network effect like that,
you have people who they join.
They're like oh, I want
my friends to see this.
They show their friends,
that kind of things.
It's just, it spreads.
And I think most of it's
been word of mouth that way.
MALE SPEAKER 1: I love it.
I love it.
And something else, I think the
odds were so far against you.
I want to bring in a quote
here from the president
of [INAUDIBLE] Sam
[INAUDIBLE], he
said that "anonymous
social networks thus far
have been in a
category of services
that they get worse
as they get better."
Unlike Facebook
and Twitter, they
get bigger-- they get
better as they get bigger.
When I heard that quote,
I thought of you guys.
I'm like wow, David and his
team are proving them wrong.
Do you believe that?
And how are you
going about that?
DAVID: Yeah, that
was an early quote.
I think he mentioned that
it would kind of eventually
trend to negativity.
And we knew that that would
be the death knell of Secret,
if that were turning that way.
So we did everything
we could in our power
to kind of moderate as much as
possible, like do-- you always
promote positivity,
and mostly productive
secrets in our product.
So we do little things in
design like little comment box.
Instead of like write a comment,
it says like something kind.
Just like drop little hints
so that hopefully things
stay like a well-lit space.
And it was funny to read
that quote because here's
a VC who believes in
solving hard problems.
And this is a very hard problem.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
DAVID: And so it only inspired
us to like really push and show
that we can do anonymity
and do it well.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Yeah, well, I can
see you guys like pinning up
this quote like locker room
material.
DAVID: Maybe I did.
Maybe I did.
With his picture.
MALE SPEAKER 1: That's a secret.
We'll post it on Secret.
Awesome.
What other challenges did
you face in the early days?
I guess we're still in
the early days of Secret,
in trying to get it out there.
You mentioned keeping
it a well-lit space.
What other hurdles did
you have to overcome?
DAVID: Well, I think
that's the biggest one.
The other one was
security, right.
Here we are with a bunch of
people coming on a platform.
And you know, it's telling us,
telling the platform things
that they're
thinking and feeling
and rumors with whatever,
like some deep, heavy stuff.
And so it's our job to keep
that locked down and secure,
and no system is perfect.
And so that's obviously an
ongoing area of research,
and an ongoing challenge
for us to make sure
that the data is safe.
And we even built
things into the product
to allow people to
say, you know what.
Like everything I
posted, like I don't
want to be associated
with it anymore, right.
So things like that we're
constantly evolving.
Because honestly, it's like
30 million credit cards being
breached, or
something like that.
Like, we can't allow
that to happen.
So that's another
challenge as well.
So security, privacy,
in addition to growth.
It's a delicate,
delicate balance.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Of
course, of course.
And talk to me about
your engagement numbers.
I was looking at the stats.
And it looks like 75% of people
with more than five friends
come back to your
platform every single day.
I mean, that's just unheard
of for a network that
is around, let alone has
started just a few months ago.
DAVID: Yeah, I think
conversation is the key.
And it's amazing to see so much
rich and deep conversations
on an anonymous platform.
Again, it's like you
wouldn't really expect that.
But what we see is we have
two cohorts in our system.
One is zero friends,
people with-- basically,
they don't have anyone
that they're connected to.
Their attention is
a little bit lower.
It more 40 to 50%,
which is still very,.
Very good and then
there's the people
who have more than one friend,
trending more towards 70%,
and then even higher.
As that goes up, it gets higher
and higher, up to about 80, 85%
in some cases.
And so the key is to get people
to engage in a conversation.
And that keeps that
hook of coming back,
like who wrote back.
Who's saying what about
what I just wrote.
And that's really, really key.
And you're right, like
those retention numbers
are the most
important thing to me.
All the press in the world,
like this is what I've learned.
All the press in the world
will not immediately get
you overnight millions of users,
especially if you are iOS only,
or Android only.
It just doesn't happen, right.
Mobile, these things take
a little bit of time.
And there's a network effect
that needs to build up.
And so I would say that
instead of looking always
at absolute numbers, even
though over time, that'll
take care of itself, if
you have good retention
and good engagement.
And that's what
we're focused on.
And that's why those are the
numbers we like to talk about
and what other-- I truly
believe other developers need
to be focused on is
just retaining users.
And the other
thing I will say is
that there are many ways
under the sun to distribute
your product through tap
[INAUDIBLE] or ads or whatever.
You can put a lot of people
at the top of the funnel.
The question is
what happens when
they get to the next
step of the funnel.
Are they staying around?
So that's what you
need to focus on.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Absoutely.
So let's talk about
the top of that funnel.
And then we'll move
down towards it.
How did you-- you mentioned
that you're in different markets
all the way spanning
into Russia how
did you-- did you
proactively outreach?
Did somebody hear about Secret,
get on a plane, go to Russia,
like by expanded there.
How exactly did it grow so fast?
It's a fascinating process.
DAVID: You know,
I wish I could--
I honestly wish I could break
it down to some sort of formula.
We've always had grand
plans, like we're
going to have ambassadors
go to colleges.
We're going to do this and that.
But again, it's just been
happening pretty quickly.
Because we've tapped into this
new network effect, right.
And who doesn't want
come on a platform
and read secrets from people.
Like that's just-- the
story tells itself, right.
As far as Russia, I remember
one morning I woke up.
It was like 3:00 AM.
I'd gotten paged.
Because I still our
main back end engineer.
So I have to deal with all that.
But I got paged.
And I woke up.
And I opened my laptop.
And I looked at the graph just
kind of like go straight up.
And I was like, what's going on.
And then I looked at the
secrets on our moderation thing.
And it was all Russian.
I'm like, we are under attack.
What is happening?
And it took a little bit.
I used Google
Translate and whatnot.
I'm like OK, these are actually
people creating real secrets.
To this day, I can't explain
how or why that happened.
It just-- I just picture
one guy like randomly
finds it in the app store
and shows someone, and then
just goes from there.
There's definitely been
some press we've done.
When we rolled
out international,
we went to Netherlands and some
places that are-- Netherlands,
93% of people are
connected internet.
It's huge.
And so these are
great, and they're
amazing social networks.
Brazil, Netherlands they're
like first adopters.
And so we went there, put
out some little press things,
get some people into it.
And then the rest has to
take care of itself, right.
And so that's kind of
been our strategy so far.
The next step for us is
to break a little bit out
of tech and more into
lifestyle and more
of a mainstream audience
and see how they do.
But again, timing is everything.
And we need to make sure
we're not going too fast, not
too far, and kind of growing
at a very steady, solid rate.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So
let's talk about that.
How do you move
into the mainstream?
Because I think some
of these startups
see that tech crunch bump.
They see press come in,
lots of initial users.
People get excited.
And then two months later, you
don't hear about those startups
again.
How are you-- what are
you doing to avoid that?
DAVID: I think right now for us,
it's a game of show and tell.
It's always showing
the kind of content
that's created on
Secret, whether we
are kind of collecting secrets
and showing it to people,
and showing them this
is the kind of content
you can find on Secret.
That way people in the
Midwest or wherever,
they see things
that relate to them.
That's I think
the real key, when
everyone-- the goal is
whenever anyone signs up
to Secret, the first
few secrets they see
should be something
relatable, something close by,
something in their campus,
something they're interested,
that kind of thing.
And they need to make that deep
connection with the product.
And that kind of
content is what helps
people, especially mainstream,
kind of connect with it
and want to use it.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So it
seems like your development
and your distribution
go hand in hand.
When the user
comes on, they want
to see content that's compelling
that keeps them coming back.
How do you make sure that those
first three posts are most
engaging?
Is it algorithms?
What are you doing to make that?
DAVID: So there's a few things.
I mean, we have
a moderation team
that's always curating
some of the best content.
They are going through stuff and
finding it and kind of picking
out things, so that
when people do come on,
that they see that kind
of stuff to kind of set
the pace and the tone
for what the product is.
I fully, fully believe
the beauty begets beauty.
What they see is
what they're going
to want to mimic and represent.
And that goes back
to the original point
of battling negativity.
If you join and you see
something extremely negative,
you see something
that's hurtful,
or see something
that's like whatever,
not safe for work,
stuff like that.
You're like what is this?
What's going on?
You kind of want to help steer
people in that direction.
And that first experience
is the most important.
The best experience,
of course, is
when they join and
they're instantly
connected to their friends.
And they have something that's
like this from a friend.
It's like someone says
even the simplest things.
Someone says like, romance me.
And it's from a friend.
You're like, is
this someone I know.
MALE SPEAKER 1: That
would make my day.
DAVID: Is this my girlfriend.
Is this-- yeah, exactly.
And you connect with
it on a deeper level,
rather than you go
to some other product
where it's just a public feed.
And it's random people.
You're like, romance me.
Whatever, I don't
care about that.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So
take me through.
When was the moment
when you were first
building the product where
it resonated with you.
When you're like, wow, I think
this could be something as big
as we see today with
what Secret has become.
When did that happen for you?
DAVID: So I remember when we're
testing with our friends--
again, we only had about
250 people on the platform.
It was a little bit
before Christmas.
And someone had
posted and said, I'm
thinking of asking my girlfriend
to marry her-- or marry me
on Christmas Day.
Is that poor form?
What do you guys think?
All these people, my friends
and my co-founders' friends,
is the intersection
of all of us,
we're giving feedback
and talking about it.
And I was like, this
is really interesting.
I wonder if she's going to find
out what's going to happen.
Then a little bit after
Christmas, my friend, Rich,
had posted on Facebook a picture
of the ring, just got engaged.
It was kind of like a reveal.
And that got me
thinking like, you
know what, there's this
new class of communication.
The things we think
and feel, things we
want to put out there.
Or we just say in private
like a dinner table,
that you can't really put
out there and feel and get
your friends to
respond to, right.
It's that other
side of the story.
And that's what I knew that we
had something, because I fully
believe, especially
with social networks,
you look at new
apps like Slingshot.
Or you look at all
these new things.
It has to create kind of,
a new type of content,
a new class of communication.
You can't just build another
Instagram and build it better.
Because we're all on Instagram.
Why is this is going-- so
you've always got to find those
new places, those
new things, where
people have to have a new
way to express themselves.
And something that
resonates with everyone.
And so that's when I kind of
like knew something was there.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
And tell me, give me a
glimpses into the future.
What's coming up for Secret?
I know you guys are having a
lot of exciting developments
to the product and adding
more experiences for users,
so it even more resonates.
What are you doing with Secret
to allow the distribution
to only grow?
DAVID: Yeah, so I think the
most important thing any product
that once you hit
product market fit,
or you feel like you've hit
it, you need to constantly
be tightening the bolts and
making sure that the product is
robust and strong, and
things aren't falling off.
You're not missing things.
You're not losing things.
You take a product
like again, Snapchat.
I love Snapchat.
I love how they've grown.
The first year, they
were slowly growing.
They were not, it was
not an overnight thing.
It took Twitter a very,
very long time, right.
These things take time.
And you just have to build up
that core and strengthen it.
And eventually, you
never when it resonates
and it goes
mainstream like that.
So number one is we're just
constantly always making sure
that push notifications
work, everything works,
people are getting quality
stuff in the stream.
The core is there.
Then we start looking at
other things like well,
we see what our users are doing.
They want to message each other.
They want to have these private
little conversations when
they connect in a
normal conversation.
So should we build a
direct messaging product.
And of course we
want to do that.
But like I said,
timing is everything.
And it needs to make sense.
And everything
you-- every time you
add a new feature
to your product,
it's kind of like a story.
You have to go back to the
beginning and reread that story
and make sure it makes
sense cohesively.
And so with that, I think direct
messaging is really, really
important.
And again, just
showing more content.
There's so-- I can't stress
enough how much good stuff
there is on our product
that a lot of people do see.
But a lot of people don't.
And we want to be able
to show some of that
and have our users
really be proud of things
they've created.
Maybe they don't
take credit for it,
like this was mine
of course, but just
show some of that really,
really good stuff.
And I think that's
really important, too.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So for me,
you mentioned that last one.
It really stuck out
for me, not taking
credit for what
you put out there.
Because I think like
on Facebook, Twitter,
so many of us just think about
wow, it's got so many likes,
it's got favorites.
It got re-tweeted.
But on your network,
none of that matters.
But people still
keep coming back.
Why?
DAVID: Well, so everyone
loves that sense or connecting
with others.
And in the heart,
or like, whatever's
the light weight
feeling that someone--
I connected with someone
out there, right.
There's someone out there
that liked what I did.
And that's just, it's a drug.
It's addictive.
And people love that.
But I will say this what's
the funniest thing to me
is when people do take
credit for their secrets.
They will literally post them on
Twitter, post them on Facebook,
and say, oh man.
I got 2000 likes on this.
They'll come back a month later
and say, it's at 3,000 likes.
And there's two things there.
With Secret, because
things continue
to spread through networks,
the half life of a given secret
can be weeks, if not months.
So if someone posts something,
and it just keeps going.
As new people come on,
they see this secret.
And they like it.
And they do it.
But yeah, my mom does
this all the time.
She'll post something and then
literally I get like a play
by play of how many hearts she's
on for whatever given secret.
It's just--
MALE SPEAKER 1:
She'll update you,
like David, I'm
at 50 hearts now.
DAVID: Yeah, Yeah, I'm
like Mom, I get it.
It's good.
But yeah, she loves it.
MALE SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
So I'm not going to ask you
to share what secrets your mom
has put out there.
But I want to ask--
DAVID: Usually it's like I can't
wait to move out to California.
I can't wait-- I love my boys.
I'm like, gee.
I wonder who this is.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Really heart
wrenching secrets there.
Really exposes yourself.
DAVID: Well, there
was one where I
was-- there was
someone who posted.
It was like, I miss the beach.
Or I miss the whatever.
I'm like oh, that's cool.
And I hearted it.
It was like, my dream one day
is to move out to California.
And I wasn't thinking,
like it just said friend.
It's like a picture of a beach.
And I'm like, you can do it.
Just kind of like support.
And then the comment was like,
well, my boys are out there.
And I'm like, Mom, dude.
So that's happened
more than once.
I
MALE SPEAKER 1: So
tell me about-- you
are the creator of Secret.
I want you to be able to
have a heart to heart here.
What's a secret that you could
tell us about your early days,
starting this startup.
And maybe a regret
or a mistake you
had, something you could share.
Forget the crowd here.
There's no cameras.
This is just a secret
that's going to be totally--
DAVID: Now that you say that.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
But why don't you
share something that may
be from your early days.
Or an insight that maybe you
wish you go back and tell
yourself, I wish I couldn't
done this differently.
DAVID: I'm extremely stubborn,
extremely to a fault.
And I think in the early days,
I had this idea for the ability
to send these
anonymous love notes,
love-- it was very personal to
me, right, to my girlfriend.
And I'm like, I want
to be able to tell her
I love her without her
knowing it's from me,
just focus on the words,
kind of like digital flowers.
And this just meant
so much to me.
And I remember I showed
my now co-founder, Chris.
I'm like, hey.
I'm working on this thing.
Let's do it.
And in the very first, I guess,
two months of our building
this, he was always pushing me.
Dude, I think we
need to-- there's
going to be bullying here.
There's going to be issues.
We've got to try
something else, again,
the broadcast model, whatever.
And it was a good month where
I was just like holding strong,
no we have to do it this way.
This is what I want.
And eventually it
took a few things,
but mostly it took Apple
basically coming down on us
and saying, nope, you
can't send anonymous SMS.
That was the-- we
couldn't do it.
We switched and pivoted.
And immediately, our friends
started using it more.
It was something
we were proud of.
And I think the biggest
thing there was just
I was far too stubborn
with my own idea
and what I wanted
to do at that time.
Because I'd built this little
thing, then actually letting go
and trying to pivot.
I think a lot of companies
make the mistake of they
will hold onto an idea and
even launch it, and then
be afraid to pivot.
But I think that's-- you
learn a lot along the way.
And you need to take that
learning and change it, right.
Never make the same mistakes
twice, that kind of thing.
And that was a big learning
experience for me, I think.
Most people don't know.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Fantastic.
So you've supplied so
much good stuff here
from sharing insights
about your early days,
even telling us about your
mom's secrets on the platform.
But I just want to
give you the space
to talk about maybe a final
piece of advice you would give
to an entrepreneur or developer
who's starting from day one,
remembering where
were in January.
And then we're going to open
up to you guys, because I'm
sure you guys have a lot
of questions to ask David.
And we'll pass around mic
so you guys get the chance.
DAVID: Yeah, I think the
biggest thing that I've learned,
so I was at Square
for a year after.
I was at Google for
five years before that.
Google's great at
managing complexity.
But that's only like
one piece of the puzzle.
The most important thing is
to keep it extremely simple,
so you can keep the entire
product, the entire thing,
in your head.
Every good idea,
every good product,
you should be able to
build in a weekend.
Pack it together in a
weekend, you have something,
and it makes sense.
I mean, you look at any
really successful product
and how it started, and
it started very simple.
Even Google itself started
very, very, very simple.
Take all these documents,
rank them in a novel way,
and then you can
search them, making it
just-- there's things you can
hack together very quickly.
And I would say that again, when
it comes to building a product,
before you launch,
simplicity is the key.
Everything you add
is already some form
of debt, that's the
most important thing.
MALE SPEAKER 1: I love it.
Cool.
So we'll open up to
questions from you guys.
And we'll pass around the mic.
Yeah, we'll get you the
mic here so everyone
can hear your question.
AUDIENCE: Could you
talk a little bit
about what your user
growth curve looks like?
DAVID: Sure.
So I don't have to repeat the
question since you have a mic.
Our user graph curve, I think--
so first of all, obviously
any product that's
growing, when you zoom out,
we're only five months old,
it's this nice like linear curve
upward.
But then when you zoom in and
you look on a day to day basis,
or you look week
over week, something
like that, you see very--
this kind of thing.
It's just on the way up,
you see really big spikes.
And then it dips a little
bit, and then spike and dip.
I would say right now
it is nerve racking.
Every time you see like
this giant spike and then
like oh, things
are slowing down.
You're like, that it.
We're out of
business, game over.
But then eventually
it picks back up.
And so I think we're still
too young to really have
this like nice, gradual,
exponential curve.
But we have microcosms of it,
which are really interesting
and nerve racking.
AUDIENCE: I didn't quite
catch the-- you started on iOS
and then left.
And where did you go from there?
And how did that happen again?
DAVID: So sorry, I started on?
AUDIENCE: iOS, is that right?
Because somebody said you
can't send anonymous SMS.
DAVID: Oh, yeah.
So we initially
built the product
to send these anonymous kind
of messages, anonymous SMS,
where you would pick
someone in the address book,
you click a button, and
then the server sends
anonymous message to the user.
And so they get a
thing that says,
hey someone has shared
a secret with you.
Here's the link.
That's against
Apple's guidelines.
There's rule 22.6.
I remember very intimately,
which apparently I
thought I read the
guidelines before we
started working on this.
And then I was really ashamed.
But they just say you cannot
send anonymous or prank SMS.
And that's really more for
carriers and things like that.
There are apps that do that.
But once you become kind of
on the radar, whatever like,
it's just not good.
So that's why most products
don't do the whole,
select a bunch of people and
we'll just send invites to them
from the server anymore.
AUDIENCE: What was your fix?
DAVID: We didn't do that.
We just built a new product.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Cool.
AUDIENCE: What do you think
about upcoming competitors
from different countries
in India, Germany,
that came same time, so they
had the same ideas, maybe around
the time.
DAVID: Yeah, so
you know, I think
that's an entire
saga in the life,
in the short life of Secret.
With competitors, we've
intimately had to face this.
There was a clone
created of Secret,
literally they exact same thing.
I mean, it's weird
seeing your own product,
like the exact same product.
And again, it grew in Russia.
But in China, this
competitor came out
and they blew up, number
one in China immediately.
And here I am
like, we're looking
like there's nothing we can do.
Because we had not
launched in China.
We weren't ready for it.
They got a huge head start.
And that was really, really
nerve racking and scary.
But you have to
focus on building
one product for the world.
And that's what we had to do.
We just don't let
it get to us, focus
on building this one product.
the meantime, we built a--
we formed a joint venture
in China.
We found a local team in China
to build our version of Secret,
to take and rebuild it.
launched about a week ago,
and as of two days ago,
became number one
in the App Store.
So you just, you gotta
stop and-- thank you.
Thank you.
You gotta just step
back and focus on
keep what you're doing.
There are clones
in China, or sorry,
in India, Indonesia,
and other places.
But we were there first.
And we got a-- we're
the innovators.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Well, so with that,
I just want to thank
David so much for coming.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID: Thank you.